our first is Brendan O'Neill bandoniel
is a journalist and editor who spike
online he's a blogger for the Telegraph
Telegraph he's author of the green
satire can I recycle my granny and 39
other eco dilemmas
he writes many publications on both
sides of the Atlantic
he has been variously described as an
angry little boy by English men a
Marxist proletarian firebrand by George
Mommy oh and a smug shite by Peter
Tatchell Brendan O'Neill I love
technology I love technology because it
has made human life so much better than
it used to be in the time when Jesus was
skulking around the planet the human
population was about 200 million people
today it's nearly 7 billion and most of
that growth has happened over the past
hundred years human life expectancy has
also rocketed upwards from a global
average of about 25 back then to around
68 today we are taller fitter grania and
freer than we have ever been before and
all of those advances are a result of
what we call technology they are a
result of our transformation of the
earth our efforts to make this planet
more hospitable to humankind of
exploitation of nature for the benefit
of man because if you look back at human
history and ask yourself a question what
is technology you will see that it is in
essence the conquering of nature
technologies the means through which we
bring more from mother nature than she
is willing to give us we have used tools
such as ploughs sickles mud furnaces
ships compasses and machines in order to
plant wheat mines smelt spin weave and
fly technology is our defiance of nature
nature creates a canyon we create a
bridge nature forgets to give us wings
we
invent the aeroplane make sure refuses
to tell us what you rhenium is good for
we experiment with it anyway and create
a technology that can light up entire
cities technology is the clearest
expression there is of mankind's
cockiness obvious refusal to live at the
mercy of that unpredictable and violent
beasts nature but how different is today
today the new technologies do not
express anything like the pioneering
spirit instead they are tools for
narcissism technology today is not about
taming the world around us it is about
obsessing over our own inner worlds our
own emotions and our own fleeting
feelings technology today does not
encourage us to go forth and multiply it
encourages us to stay home and navel
gaze where the old technologies were
tools for exploration the new
technologies are tools of retreat the
most serious problem with the new
technologies is that they invite not
that they invite us to lead busy and
frenetic lives but that they invite us
to be meek and unambitious to become
estranged from the old idea of outward
human endeavor
ours is an era in which there is
extraordinary hostility toward any
technology which tampers with nature
alongside the wild almost demented
celebration of new technologies that
merely allows us to preen and pamper
ourselves so drilling for oil despite
using some of the most remarkable
technology created by man is frowned
upon seen as the equivalent of raping
Gaia save the word nuclear power to the
average member of the chattering classes
and watch them flutter on their
macchiato the word dam has become a
dirty word despite the fact that dams
represent possibly the high point of
human technology where vast waves of
water we muster vast waves of water in
order to provide electricity to millions
upon millions of people all those
technologies are looked upon as bad all
of them are high up on the list of the
liberal elites least favorite things
meanwhile the new technologies which are
now little more than flimsy forms of
communication or hours of
self-reflection are championed the
iPhone is worshipped Facebook and
Twitter enjoy an extraordinary amount of
cultural validation the Internet is seen
as the greatest invention ever give or
take a few downsides such as its
Nigerian spammers and rampant
pornography planet altering technologies
are demonized nude altering technologies
are celebrated technologies that change
the physical world around us which
forced nature to reveal her secrets are
seen as evil technologies which allow us
to retreat into a virtual world to take
refuge from physical reality in a
universe of blabber are seen as good in
today today we even have the curious
situation where activists utilize the
new technologies as part of their crazy
war against old-fashioned technology so
privately educated environmentalists use
their iPhones and their iPads to
organize campaigns against cheap floods
and other white trash activities which
they regard as harmful to the planet
Greenpeace makes full use of the
Internet to spread its unhinged
propaganda about the dangers of nuclear
power and oil exploration the new
technologies have been turned into
weapons against the old idea that
technology should remake the world
according to humanity's needs and in
humanity's image technology was once
about humanizing the planet increasing
the human footprint the new technology
is about shrinking the human footprint
from wind power to choir to aeroplanes
to electric cars all the new
technological breakthroughs are about
rein in humanity in limiting his impact
on surroundings making him a good
virtual creature rather than a bad
physical one in essence the new
technologies facilitate our retreat from
making history they facilitate our
backward desire to shrivel up and
hibernate rather than to explore
expand and of course it is on the
technologies spot we get the
technologies we deserve so in the 16th
and 17th centuries an era of when the
spirit of exploration was strong we got
vast ships capable of traversing entire
oceans in that post-war positive moment
of the 1950's we got nuclear power and
the space race and today at a time of
great human meekness and fear and risk
aversion we get technologies that allow
us to hide from the world and to hide
from our responsibilities to make
history which only Lau allow us to
reflect on ourselves rather than on the
future of humankind new technologies
make a bad situation worse the real
problem is not that they turn us into
super busy Twitterers or Facebook
checkers but they're they flatter modern
man's extraordinary level of historic
laziness and lack of ambition Roger hi
Jeff and Roth Rory Sutherland for three
minutes
your witness
the key point is what people use
technology for and what they create it
for and I think technology always suits
the circumstances in which we find
ourselves so there's no reason why the
internet couldn't be the most wonderful
thing of all time and even why the
iPhone and the iPad and these other
things could be great devices but in an
era in which people are obsessed with
themselves when we have kind of
retreated from history and and making
the world anew those technologies become
tools of narcissism so it's more a
historic human shift which then changes
the nature of Technology but I think it
sounds of time it happened sometime
around the late eighties early nineties
yeah there's nothing wrong with it but
but when it replaces everything else
that's that's pretty bad and when you
look at Twitter and all you see are all
these crazy green people saying oh god
there's another oil spill you know the
Fukushima accident shows that we can
never have nuclear power when you see in
the new technologies a real hatred for
what technology used to represent that's
when all innovation it simply too
equally as a possible Marxist I'm not
sure whether you are or not having
problems and actually the Soviet
obsession with a big heavy industry
okay well the Soviet Union was at
Marxist it was Stalinist there's a very
important difference between those two
codes no the real problem today is low
ambitions low horizons just a refusal to
get to grips with the world we live in
and to remake it in our own image a good
example is aeroplanes the only
developments being made in flying these
days are to make aeroplanes quieter
because they have all these people
constantly moaning about the noise of
airplanes to make them less polluting
because of all these green say no we
can't have polluting planes and to input
email so that people in the sky can
continue facebooking and twittering and
being self-obsessed there's no focus on
making them faster making them bigger
making them go further making little
better machines it's all about the low
ambitions for low horizons and
Technology molds itself around those low
horizons and that's what the new
technology represent we're going to have
to the reasoning that were just all the
law of diminishing returns
and air resistance increases of the tube
of velocity so at some point we are
right to switch our focus from speeds to
some other measure okay respond to move
I don't think that's a good enough
explanation
you know Concorde was our fastest plane
it's now been decommissioned and nothing
has come to replace it we need higher
ambitions thank you very much